What do you think about in terms of this co-evolution of, um,
the work around brain computer interfaces and maybe
a neuro Lincoln and Elan
seeing Neuralink in particular as, uh,
its longterm mission as a symbiosis with artificial intelligence.
So like giving a greater bandwidth
channel of communication between technology,
AI systems and the biological, uh,
neural networks of our human mind.
What do you think about this idea of connecting directly to the brain
in, in AI systems?
I mean, okay. I've, I've listened to your podcasts with Alon.
I've listened to Alon before very Intel, obviously super smart guy. Um,
I think this is already, I mean, not in the specific ways that he is doing it,
but I think we are already doing that. Okay. And I,
I can give you some examples. Um,
and there are really trivial examples,
but they do make the point and this is one of them.
So before he started this research on UFO's and
UAPs and technology,
I actually was looking at the effects of technology
and in particular media on religion.
And what I did was I was lucky to be asked to be a
consultant for various movies. And, uh,
one in particular I learned a lot from, and that was the conjuring.
So I was a history consultant for the conjuring.
It happens to be my field it's Catholic studies. Right.
And you've got these people who are real people and they're, you know,
exercising demons and things like that. Okay. So I thought, wow,
this is a great example for me. You know, I didn't do it for the money.
It doesn't pay well, but I did it to learn, right.
So I work closely with the screenwriters who I work with now all the time with I
work with them all the time now. And what I found was this,
I found that as the most interesting part of the creation of this movie was the
editing process because they would use it,
it would go through editing and they would use test audiences.
And a lot of the test audiences, um, would be like, you know,
there's like these things where they test their flicker rates and things like
that, the eye flicker rates. And so, and,
and when it goes really intense,
they did go to UC Irvine and they do this thing called cognitive consumption,
which is basically, um, or I'm sorry,
cognitive consumerism, where they basically hook,
test audiences up to EKG and they read their brains and they figure out
which scenes create the most. Yeah.
And so they cut out all the other scenes. Okay. So we're getting is,
we're getting like this drug when we go to the movies or when we do video games
and when we watch literally physiologically responding to
our technologies, so we're already there,
we're already interfacing with them physiologically. So that's my example. Now,
the, the kind of thing that he's doing, uh, Musk is doing with link,
I say, go for it. That's awesome. I hope he does it. You know, I'm fascinated.
I want it to happen. Um, why do I want it to happen? Because I think that,
well, first it's inevitable that it's going to happen. Um,
I also want to point out that [inaudible] was trying to get this done back in
the sixties and the seventies. He was writing papers about. In fact,
the ARPANET, the pro pro internet, um,
was called augmentation of the human intellect.
So we've been doing this for a while. Okay. So, um, props to Elon Musk,
but we've been thinking about this for a good time. Um,
we've even been visioning it. Okay.
So there was a really interesting Jesuit priest.
Who's French, uh, tell your day Chardon. I don't know if you know who he is.
If not, he's fascinating. He was a, he was actually a soldier, uh,
before he became a priest. And so he believed,
he also saw what he called a biosphere. Now,
this guy is talking in like the early 20th century, like the 1917, 19,
you know, that time period. And so basically he,
he said and wrote about this thing called the newest sphere.
And he basically said there will be a point when we merge with our technology
and it's going to be somewhat like some kind of a biosphere.
We have this atmosphere and then we have the stratosphere and this is going to
be this biosphere. And we're all going to be hooked into it mentally.
So we'll be able to communicate in a way in which we don't communicate now. So,
you know, that sounds so similar to the singularity.